herzlich willkommen hier in rauschen im
wind
herzlich willkommen schön dass sie gas
inc in deutschlands herzliche von ihnen
zu hause
kürzlich sagte mir einen zuschauer nach
einer live aufzeichnung sie moderieren
die sternstunden so souverän wie eine
frau am herd
kleiner scherz am rande oder bereits
gravierender art packs sexismus und wie
ist das eigentlich mit der praktikantin
die mit ihrem vorgesetzten aufs
hotelzimmer geht weil er was besprechen
möchte und dann stellt sie fest die
besprechung findet im bett statt
ist das eine machtmissbrauch seinerseits
oder er neue lied ihrerseits klar ist
eigentlich nur der geschlechterkampf ist
mitnichten ausgefochten unter hass tag
mit two thematisieren frauen seit
oktober 2017 in den sozialen medien
sexuelle übergriffe missbrauch und
diskriminierung
die aktivistin tarone burki hatte den
hashtag bereits 2006 benutzt um auf
sexuellen missbrauch an
afroamerikanischen frauen aufmerksam zu
machen
elf jahre später griff die us
amerikanische schauspielerin alyssa
milano hashtag me to wieder auf nach dem
vergewaltigungs vorwürfe gegen den film
produzenten harvey weinstein publik
geworden waren
seitdem haben millionen von frauen
diesen hashtag verwendet um gegen den
alltäglichen sexismus zu protestieren
neben den vorkommnissen in hollywood
führte die heftige debatte auch zu
diskussionen um sexuelle belästigung in
der musikbranche in der wissenschaft und
in der politik doch die kampagne rief
auch gegnerinnen auf den plan
schauspielerin catherine deneuve oder
schriftstellerin thea dorn etwa warnten
vor dem klima einer totalitären
gesellschaft mito sei eine kampagne
öffentliche anschuldigungen ein neuer
sozialer planer eine der schärfsten
kritikerinnen ist die philosophin svenja
flaßpöhler der mitte feminismus
reproduziere ein patt reales welt und
weiblichkeit bild männer würden unter
generalverdacht gestellt frauen in eine
opferrolle gedrängt
ganz anders sieht es die feministin
margarete stokowski für sie ist es
typisch für sexualisierte gewalt dass
das opfer letztlich zum schuldigen
gemacht wird der kampf der geschlechter
geht offenbar in die nächste runde
der kampf der geschlechter geht in die
nächste runde auch an unserem stammtisch
werden wir jetzt darüber diskutieren
ich freue mich sehr über die gäste heute
abend ich ganz herzlich begrüße kathrin
numark kulturjournalistin aus zürich und
aus berlin
svenja flaßpöhler chefredakteurin des
philosophie magazins in berlin und
konrad paul liessmann wieder so viel
professor ausliegen herzlich willkommen
thomas köhler
sie sagen in diesem kleinen büchlein
dieser streitschrift die potente frau
der minister muss sieben tiere
patriarchale denk und verhaltensmuster
eigentlich war doch das gegenteil das
team sicher man muss aber klar sehen
dass natürlich die patriarchale geprägte
kultur geschichte den frauen erstmal
nichts zugetraut hat na also keine
autonomie keine potenz kein sexuelles
begehren und genau das wiederholt sich
jetzt auch wenn die intention vielleicht
eine andere war doch in dieser ganzen
debatte durch dimitri initiative denn es
ist ja augenfällig dass frauen selbst in
situationen in denen sie
handlungsmöglichkeiten hätten eigentlich
keine autonomie keine mündigkeit
zugetraut wird sondern ihnen lediglich
sozusagen zugetraut wird dass sie sich
im nachhinein dann durch einen tweet
sozusagen beschweren
das halte ich für tatsächlich für
infantilisierung werden frauen klein
gemacht und da machen sich frauen selber
klein und schreiben sich tatsächlich in
einer opferrolle fest die in der
heutigen zeit die eben dezidiert kein
patriarchates zumindest im rechtlichen
sinne nicht die sie einfach nicht mehr
haben müssen machen sich frauen selber
klein in der kampagne weil ich gestehen
dass ich diese sache ganz anders sehen
und zwar bin ich durchaus nicht der
meinung also ich habe mit dem ziel einer
potenten frau gar kein problem
womit ich ein problem habe oder wo ich
einen starken descent sehe zwischen uns
ist das wie ich wird diese miete
kampagne warb wahrnehmen also sie sagen
mito ist ein fest schreiben in einer
opferrolle
man bleibt ganz passiv wenn etwas
passiert und beschwert sich nachher auf
twitter ich halte das für eine wirklich
verzerrte und verzerrende und auch sehr
differenzierte darstellung dessen was
mieter in gewisser weise das ist ein
sehr farbiges gebildes war mal ein
hashtags gabi viele tweets aber es gab
ja auch eine wirklich sehr große
intellektuelle mediale journalistische
debatte über die frage wie sich männer
und frauen begegnen und wo ist das
dysfunktional und das jetzt zu
reduzieren auf einen so quasi ideellen
kern der irgendwie passivität von frauen
fest schreibe und nach hinten hinterher
beklage sich beklagen und keine
autonomie von frauen das bin ich
tatsächlich falsch also ich finde
auch gerade mit diesem polemischen
gestus zu sagen die bewegung die am
stärksten also seit den 70er jahren hat
keine diskussion so stark die frage nach
der sexualität aufs tapet gebracht wie
die miete diskussionen zu sagen ja ihr
habt das leider ist alles falsch gemacht
wenn es das ganz anders das was findest
zu polemisch da ist mir die polemik ich
würde gerne an die methode watte
anschließend sagen jetzt müssen wir
sexualität noch ganz ganz ganz viele
themen auf den tisch war mir eins nach
dem anderen
sie wollten ganz kurz darauf reagieren
na ja die frage ist doch wie wird es
thematisiert das ist doch die verlage
und das problem ist doch dass einfach in
dieser methode abate es überhaupt keinen
wirklichen ernsthaften dialog zwischen
den geschlechtern gibt die tour ist ein
reiner anklage diskurs von frauen an
männer der über die öffentlichkeit
gespielt wird und das wird meines
erachtens nicht zu einer dynamisierung
und zu einer wirklichen
auseinandersetzung sondern zu einer
verhärtung des geschlechter flender zeit
noch an der realität vorbei es haben
sich doch sehr viele männer in der
öffentlichkeit mit diesen fragen
beschäftigt ankläger wir hören jetzt
gleichen machen aber ich wollte kurz
sagen nämlich jens jessen der hat in der
zeit sich gewehrt und hat gesagt vielen
dank für diese großartige zur debatte
titel des artikels war der bedrohte man
fühlen sie sich bedroht charisma kraft
also wenn ich mir so umsehe und sie
gerade mit einerseits umzingelt wenn
jetzt sagen würde von schönen frauen
könnte man das sofort wieder negativ
auslegen
nein ich fühle mich nicht bedroht
verstehe auch die debatte nur zur hälfte
das liegt in der natur des geschlechts
also was wir jetzt bei diesem szenario
auffällt ist natürlich schon dass dieser
diskurs an manchen ecken in eine
richtung gegangen ist wo man als man das
gefühl haben kann
ich weiß es wirklich nicht mehr was ist
jetzt richtig was ist falsch wie verhält
man sich
wie begegnet man einander wie begegnet
man dem anderen geschlecht
wann ist etwas noch erlaubt wenn es ist
übergriffig wann ist es schon überhaupt
zusammen
grenze oder schon tatsächlich ausgeübte
sexuelle gewalt denn eines war ja doch
klar in dieser debatte begonnen hat das
mit ganz harten
vergewaltigungs-vorwürfen gegen diesen
habe einst ihn vergewaltigungsvorwürfe
gelten in allen zivilisierten ländern
als kriminelle akte die von gerichten zu
verfolgen sind bis heute ist übrigens
noch keiner der angeklagten tatsächlich
rechtmäßig verurteilt worden nur sozial
nur in den medien verurteilt worden
und dann ist offensichtlich eine
eigendynamik entstanden
diese frage der vergewaltigung im
hinblick auf belegs belästigung im
hinblick auf plumpe annäherungsversuche
so sehr ausgedehnt hat dass jede form
einer nicht tadellos und oder nicht das
korrekte impfung können oder nicht die
eigenen vorstellungen von begegnung
zwischen den geschlechtern durchgezogene
handlung jeder dieser form stand sofort
einen verdacht ganz böse zu sein und
dann eingereiht zu werden in genau diese
formen von tatsächlicher über
griffigkeit gewalttätigkeit und von
machtmissbrauch ich würde ja gern mal
wirklich diesen begriff machtmissbrauch
diskutieren dann macht kann glaube ich
moralisch gesehen nur eine art und weise
gebraucht werden dass immer jemand das
ausmisten findet dass wir keine macht-
lassen sie uns einen punkt ganz kurz
darauf nehmen sie haben vorhin gesagt
sie können auf man ja immer nur die
hälfte verstehen naturgemäß würde das
auch heißen dass zum beispiel eine weiße
person naturgemäß immer nur die hälfte
von rassismus verstehen kann frau gleich
sie haben die sanfte ironie in dieser
bemerkung über hörerfragen des wagens
natürlich ironisch gemeint ich glaube
natürlich das gegenteil ich glaube ich
natürlich dass jedes vernünftige wesen
in der lage ist sich in jedes andere
vernünftige wesen hineinzuversetzen und
dass man natürlich aus man über fragen
die eine frau betreffen genauso
diskutieren kann wie als weißer fragen
die nicht weise betreffen oder
angehörige anderer kulturen betreffen
das halte ich ja für den großen vorzug
als menschen dass wir nicht in unserem
denken in seinem einfühlungsvermögen in
unserem
vollzug dass der handlungen und der
gefühle anderer zurückgeworfen sind auf
der nassen del mar auf fast allen er
definierte biologische kulturelle
sexuelle oder sagen aber etwas ganz
wichtiges finde ich dann doch eben
gesagt in dieser bemerkung nämlich dass
es gibt eben zwei verschiedene
wahrnehmungsweisen auch von sexuellen
situationen ja es gibt zwei verschiedene
perspektiven und sexualtherapeutin
können sagen sehr ausdrücklich ulrich
clement zum beispiel dass männer
sozusagen sexuelle situationen einfach
anders interpretieren zeichen anders
interpretieren damit rechtfertige ich
keine vergewaltigung und keine nötigung
ich glaube nur und da komme ich auch sie
jetzt noch mal zurück das ist doch
wirklich darum darum geht sozusagen sich
immer wieder zu verständigen direkt zu
verständigen in den situationen und es
bringt für diese verständigung überhaupt
nicht im nachhinein völlig
undifferenzierte schmidt zu twittern me
to was denn ich auch heißt dass ich auch
ich bin vergewaltigt worden heißt es ich
bin wer bei belästigt worden das ist das
ist ungefähr entsorger genau das was sie
fordern ist meiner meinung nach ein
integraler bestandteil dieser debatte
die wir jetzt haben seit letztem oktober
natürlich begann es mit
vergewaltigungs-vorwürfen es weitete
sich dann auf auf die beschreibung einer
allgemeinen dysfunktional i tät der
geschlechtlichen begegnung und da ist es
natürlich so zu sagen theoretisch auch
interessanter vergewaltigung ist ein
straftatbestand dann müssen wir keine
gesetze ändern da brauchen wir keine
diskussion
wir brauchen das aufdecken hinter habe
ihm einst ihn waren journalisten schon
sehr lange her
dieses system aufzudecken das war der
weiße wal des journalismus sie haben ihn
dann endlich erwischt die andere frage
wo man das dann auf weitet da finde ich
wirklich interessant und da berühren wir
eigentlich die fragen die sie auch
interessieren und ich glaube sie werden
diskutiert nämlich genau die frage wie
ist die situation für mich wie es sie
für dich wie haben wir eine situation
wahrgenommen
das ist ja in einer epischen breite auch
diskutiert worden
im zuge in den letzten monaten es gab so
viele artikel wo männer gesagt haben
also ich habe damals eine situation so
wahrgenommen im nachhinein frage ich
mich ob ich das so sagen mir klar war
wie das für die frau wirkt aber lest
selbst verliert das ist das wahrlich
genau aber es ist doch wahrlich das was
in mito also im zuge dieses ganzen
wo ist dass solche differenzen
erfahrungen plötzlich moralisch
kommentiert wenn und zwar eindeutig
konsultiert werden und hinterher nur
darauf kommt es war nur eine andere
wahrnehmung und zieht man dann zurück
genauso wie bei denjenigen die sondern
mit kampagne angeklagt war sind von den
medien stets heraus es war nicht sehr
der ruf ist ruiniert der job ist weg
aber es war nichts das sind doch genau
die fälle der letzten wochen und monaten
diskutiert und ich muss den schnitt
machen über den sozialen drama über die
ganze frage wie gehen sie damit um
möchte ich nachher noch sprechen ich
möchte kurz noch bleiben bei der frage
was daran ist eigentlich ein opfer
diskurs weil das sicher auch eine ihrer
thesen und darüber hat mir am anfang
gesprochen also eine reproduktion von
patriarchalen denken die frau ist immer
das opfer und genau das tut sie in dem
sie darum twittert das ungefähre these
ich habe nachgefragt bei franziska
schutzbach einer gender forscherin und
die glaubt nicht dass mein opfer diskurs
ist meiner meinung nach ist me to kein
reiner opfer diskurs natürlich gibt es
opfer in diesem diskurs also ich denke
das muss man auch nicht schönreden die
frauen die gesprochen haben haben zum
teil tatsächlich ganz ganz schlimme
dinge erfahren und manche von ihnen
würden sich als opfer bezeichnet
andere bezeichnen sich als betroffene da
gibt es ja auch sehr unterschiedliche
empfindungen von frauen frau flaßpöhler
fordert jetzt eine neue potenz von den
frauen und da muss ich sagen ich finde
wir waren gerade monate lang relativ
potent wir haben öffentlich kritik
formuliert wir haben laut gesagt was uns
nicht passt viele frauen hatten den mut
dinge zu berichten die sie vor 20 jahren
vielleicht erlebt haben und jetzt mit
ein bisschen distanz den mut gefunden
haben diese dinge zu formulieren
also ich denke mito ist ganz klar auch
aus einer position der stärke heraus
formuliert worden und ist sicher nicht
nur ein opfer diskurs ihre position
also ich denke auch dass man svenja
goltermann hat ja auch ein interessanter
artikel dazu gemacht also dass die
autorin aus zürich
das natürlich nie tue also dass man
überhaupt opfer erfahrungen in dieser
weise öffentlich macht eine historische
entwicklung hinter sich hat es darin
durchaus nicht nur eine schwäche zu
sehen ist und gerade auch eine stärke
ich glaube auch tatsächlich mit fängt an
mit vergewaltigungs-vorwürfen
nötigungsvorwürfe da geht es um
opposition
ich glaube nicht dass man die tatsache
dass wir jetzt alle schon so lange und
so intensiv und auch durchaus mit dem
ziel daran etwas zu ändern darüber reden
wie männer mit frauen umgehen und frauen
mit männern umgehen dass das eine
position der schwäche oder eine art von
opfer des kurses drin und der wird so
sehr unterstellen dass weil sie
sozusagen sagen da sind wir in der
passivität natürlich ist unsere gesamte
kultur durchdrungen von patriarchalen
mustern ist es aber nicht so dass bloß
mit true das reproduziert es ist
generell so dass wir natürlich hier
immer noch in einem suboptimalen
männlich aktivität weiblicher genosse
biete aber nicht versprechen aber ich
denke dass doch wenn man das anklage ist
man noch nicht darin ist man so sein
also sie auch eine normative hoffen dass
sei das mittel hauptsächlich also es ist
ein hauptschuldiger re produzent dieser
haupt schuldig habe ich gesagt ich hab
gesagt wäre produziertes und ihr ist
genau das tun doch alle also sei es
momentan nicht ich bin zum einhaken also
das problem ist dass mieter alles vom
staat und von den männern erwartet aber
nichts von den frauen das heißt es wird
nicht gesehen inwiefern die frauen ein
bestimmtes patriarchale denken stützen
und zwar genau dadurch dass sie sexuell
passiv sozusagen passiv bleiben in
bestimmten situationen dass sie
letztlich ein und da würde ich klar
sagen ein kultur eine kulturell
anerzogene gefälligkeit reproduzieren ja
so und man will den man ja nicht
enttäuschen wenn wir ihn vielleicht auch
nicht verletzen und jetzt nochmal um ein
beispiel zu nennen und da finde ich den
auch gerade wieder einiges durcheinander
natürlich gibt es opfer ja die die
wirklich keine chance haben aber es
wurde ja gerade in deutschland beim wdr
prominenten fall verhandelt ja wohl
irgendwie eine ehemalige volontärin sich
öffentlich geäußert hat in der
süddeutschen zeitung und also ihren
ihrem kollegen ihren vorgesetzten auch
an den pranger gestellt hat dafür dass
das ist sozusagen die vorgeschichte die
sie auch ganz freimütig erzählt also die
waren häufig zu sein
einen trinken haben sich wunderbar
unterhalten auch so ein bisschen
sexuelle fantasien ausgetauscht er hat
ihr sehr offen erzählt dass er noch
offene beziehung mit seiner frau führt
usw
er lädt sie zu sich nach hause ein
sie macht es und wundert sich dann dass
frau und kinder nicht da sind
irgendwann sind die beiden zusammen im
hotel und er schreibt irgendwie nachts
eine eine sms wo er sagt kommen doch
auch zimmer 310 und sie geht auf zimmer
310 ich weiß jetzt nicht ob 310 meyer
geht auf 310 und wunder schreibt dann ja
und dann habe ich mich gewundert dass er
jetzt gar nicht mit mir über meine
arbeit reden will nach zum 3 ich stehe
hier mit meinem stift und meine chancen
sehr naiv dar ag.de sie ist doch ich
meine dazu da den man für anzuklagen für
die eigenen naivität und gefälligkeit
und wirklich man muss sagen jetzt ganze
würde ich sagen ich so ziemlich alle
visierung ist es für sie nicht auch so
wenn sie mit frauen sprechen dass die
meisten sagen hinter vorgehaltener hand
weil nicht alle bauen das twittern me
too
die meisten haben irgendwie schon erlebt
das handy irgendwo waren wo sie nicht
haben wollten dass machtspiele im gang
warten so weiter sind solche geschichten
nicht auch dazu da alle die vielen
vielen beispiele die ich ja gibt dann
einfach weg zu schieben alles in einen
ich würde nie behaupten dass wir das
patriarchat sozusagen imaginäre schon
überall so in den fantasien in dem was
ich ein gekapert hat in unser verhalten
in unser denken dass wir das insofern
schon überwunden haben wir sind
natürlich tief immer noch tief drin wir
hat tragen diese dieses erbe immer noch
in uns nur ich glaube die frage ist doch
wie überwinden wir darf ja am wasser wie
potent tv ton ihre patente frau was tut
die denn in dieser attraktive potente
frau sozusagen die thematisiert die
clark nicht nur an sondern die guckt
auch tatsächlich bei sich selber
inwiefern trage ich das denn noch in mir
drin
inwiefern sie woher kommt es denn
eigentlich dass ich möglicherweise gar
keinen zugang habe zu meinem sexuellen
wollen und meinem willen ja also was
nützt eine gesetzesverschärfung wie in
deutschland wo es irgendwie jetzt wo
jetzt gesagt wird nicht mehr die gewalt
ist strafbar sondern die missachtung
eines willen wenn frauen oft gar nicht
wissen was sie sexuell wollen auch das
können sexualtherapeutin bestätigen dass
frauen viel weniger einen zugang haben
zu ihren art zu ihren arabischen
fantasien er das heißt da muss man doch
hingucken das ist doch ein blinder fleck
der debatte
herr ließ waren sie sind geschlagen
überhaupt es überlegungen ein haken kann
also ich könnte vielleicht der ein oder
andere sexualtherapeuten noch einen tipp
geben auch männer wissen nicht immer was
sie sexuell wollen und da sind sich auch
nicht immer im klaren darüber sollen sie
jetzt wollen sie jetzt wollen sie nicht
was wird erwartet was wird nicht
erwartet
das ist das eine das andere ist
natürlich eine form von naivität wie die
in den von ihnen geschilderten beispiel
da kann man sich wirklich nur denken das
gibt es nicht mehr so naiv kann nicht
mal eine praktikantin bei einem
medienunternehmen medienunternehmen sein
sondern da kann man schon als man auch
das gefühl haben da wird einfach eine
raffinierte strategie angewandt und
natürlich das ist ja vielleicht auch in
der weltgeschichte schon hin und wieder
vorgekommen sind auch frauen im stande
das begehren der männer für ihre zwecke
zu steuern und sie wissen so zu sagen in
welche besser jemand geraten kann wenn
er mit bestimmten reizen konfrontiert
wird und die im operiert werden und das
kann man natürlich auch ausnützen und
dann 30 jahre später mit sozusagen und
nachdem man dann aufgrund der
vorkommnisse karriere gemacht hat sich
nun als opfer darzustellen
materialistisch betrachtet höchst
raffiniert respekt aber in dieser
naivität nehme ich das natürlich
niemanden ab dass wir die wirklich
bedeuten die frau in einer art und weise
für dumm und unfähig und naiv
darzustellen naiv eine situation
einzuschätzen
also um drei uhr in der nacht zum modell
zimmer zu gehen und so glauben jetzt
wird die stadt gemacht
das kann es ja wirklich nicht sein da
wird man wirklich alle da wird man
klischees bestätigen die nicht einmal
das patria hut gehabt hat ich freue mich
immer wer entscheidet übrigens waren
etwas funktionales und wann etwas bis
funktional ist wenn ihr einheiten
natürlich wäre das okay
das haben wir sehr viele frauen
entschied am 21 neben zwei beteiligt
sehen ist immer ein problem wenn einer
entscheidet was funktional und
dysfunktional ist
verloren das ist nicht richtig wenn zwei
beteiligt sind und einer entscheidung
für mich stimmt das nicht stimmt okay
und ich nicht genau also dann kann der
andere noch sagen aber für mich ist
super das heißt dann nicht
aber nein das reicht kann sicher nicht
worauf ich raus wollte das mag jetzt ein
bisschen ketzerische these sein dass er
einen wirklich funktionierenden
patriarch diese vorstellungen und diese
regeln wer wann was von wem zu erwarten
habt noch funktioniert haben und man
wusste etwa im mittelalter wie man seine
dame gegenüber zu verhalten hat ja gut
die frauen hat ja auch die
vergewaltigung in der ehe einfach
hinzunehmen oder ist eine andere also
lassen wir das mal ja aber das ist das
jetzt das ist ein guten bei ist ein
gutes beispiel und zeichnet würde ich
dass solche konzepte reformbedürftig
sehen ja aber ich glaube schon dass man
natürlich diese die funktionalität auch
so sehen kann und viele dieser
alltäglichen beispielen die jetzt
reproduziert werden weisen darauf hin
dass einfach dass das gefühl dafür
verloren gegangen ist wie man sich in
bestimmten situationen jemandem
gegenüber zu verhalten haben und auf der
anderen seite auch das gefühl
offensichtlich dafür verloren gegangen
ist war in der tat sagen sagen kann
natürlich stimmt zusätzlich nein
und dann muss sozusagen der andere egal
ob mann oder frau akzeptieren
das passt jetzt los habe nun mal klar
sie haben einander ausreden so normale
situation der zwischen menschen und
unterschied geben auch ihr heim und
immer wieder vor es ist vom 08 und das
ist ja das interessante also wie sie
sagen die werden schon wissen nicht mehr
wie sie in situationen reagieren sondern
wir haben natürlich sind wir in einer
sexuell verunsichert anlage und zwar von
allen geschlechtern weil es quasi
gewisse alte standorts und rituale nicht
mehr gültig sind man hat neue modelle
der sexualität entworfen und ist sich
noch nicht ganz sicher wie man sie aus
leben soll
und das führt dann eben zu einer
verunsicherung und ich kann nicht
vollständig dem folgen dass man sagt es
wird irgendwie als natürlich gibt es
einen anklagen klagen den tonfall und es
gibt fälle wo man denken das ist jetzt
vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll hier das
als anlage zu formulieren
aber trotzdem würde ich sagen dass die
debatten die wir gesehen haben in den
letzten monaten weit über das hinaus
gingen dass man jetzt gesagt hat
vergewaltigung oder plumpe anmache ist
alles das selbe männer sind täter frauen
sind opfer es war sehr differenziert und
es ist natürlich gerade in dem moment wo
wir über darüber redet wie es das
funktional wirklich so differenziert
gewesen wäre hätte keiner getwittert
allein es war schon auf twitter nicht so
undifferenziert und ich weise darauf hin
die er ursprünglich in mainz den stories
die ja auch ethisch in der länge waren
in diesem report in oslo entfernt
geschrieben dass die panther geschehen
hat mit den new york times und die new
yorker das war wahnsinnig differenziert
es waren ob handlungsmöglichkeiten von
frauen wer hat sich wie gewährt wer hat
sich physisch gewährt wer hat sich
verbal gewehrt wäre es aus dem zimmer
rausgegangen wer hat anwälte
eingeschaltet wird eine anlage in
gemeinsame schon dass die gesamte
handlungsoption frau raffaela debatte
stand von anfang an fest dass männer die
vergewaltigen hinter gitter gehöre
gehabt da sind wir uns ja alle einig ich
wollte noch eine eine formulierung
aufnehmen die sie gesagt haben das war
nämlich finde ich sehr bezeichnet werden
gesagt wir haben das gefühl dafür
verloren wie wir uns zu begegnen haben
und man könnte doch eigentlich eher
sagen wir haben das gefühl noch gar
nicht gefunden weil wir eben so lange in
diesen festen reglementierungen waren
die uns im grunde genommen es abgenommen
haben ein gefühl dafür zu entwickeln was
will eigentlich was wollen männer was
wollen frauen wie können wir uns sexuell
wirklich befriedigend tief befriedigend
begegnen
das glaube ich ist wirklich eine aufgabe
vor der wir jetzt stehen und vielleicht
noch mal daran anknüpfen wir uns halt
von sex und sexualität die rede ist ich
glaube dass ein ganz fundamentaler
fehler dieser debatte auch ist so zu tun
als gäbe es hier gewalt und hier gibt es
sozusagen eine reine von gewalt gänzlich
freie von macht gänzlich freie
vollkommen und ambivalente sexualität
ich glaube das ist ein irrglaube
sexualität nichts ich würde sogar so
weit gehen und sagen nichts am sexuellen
akt es harmlos und wir haben vorhin wir
haben schon über die verführung
gesprochen die verführung jemanden zu
verführen da steckt das führen drin das
ist man weckt in einem anderen einen
willen der so noch gar nicht vorlag dass
die verführung ist immer nah an der
manipulation sie sagen sie gehen ja noch
ein schritt weiter sie sagen der eine
welt ohne den lässt
in wien will in letzter konsequenz eine
welt ohne verführung ja weil jede
belästigung in der gefahr ist als
umgekehrt jede verfügung ist in der
gefahr als belästigung wahrgenommen zu
haben doch davon ab finde ich den den
typen der mich da jetzt anspricht und
der irgendwie beharrt finde ich den
attraktiv wenn ich den nicht agieren bin
ich in stimmung bin ich nicht also es
hängt von so vielen dingen ab und auch
die tatsache dass man das natürlich das
begehren auch immer davon lebt dass man
selbstverständlich widerstände
überwindet dass man das gefühl hat ich
ich bleibe da jetzt dran
und ja das problem ist doch eigentlich
nur dass wir das ausschließlich den
männer zu bestehen und die frau als
verführerin immer noch ein riesen tabus
da bin ich mit denen einfach alles
klasse es ist ein problem wir haben auch
noch zu oft werden frauen die sexuell
aktiv sind oder sind auch schlosser
tiefe ergriffen begreifen werden als
[ __ ] bestätigt es gibt ja im moment
auch mit slutwalks und so weiter den
versuch die [ __ ] ähnlich wie schwul
oder so zum positiven wort umzuformen
nein aber was ich zu der verführung
sagen wollte ja natürlich ist eine
verführung aber ich möchte gerne einfach
dieses wunderbare wort kommunikation mit
innenraum bringen
also natürlich ist es immer eine
interaktion die ein risiko hat aber die
natürlich nicht in der grenze übertreten
enden muss ich glaube tatsächlich dass
also zumindest einer jetzt sehr
begrenzten erfahrung und beobachtung
nach die annäherung an eine person die
man noch nicht kennt mit einem
gespielten partnern ist es anders immer
so ist dass man und zwar nicht unbedingt
im sinne einer schriftlichen
unterschrift jahren vielleicht ich will
aber dass steuersünder rein da steuert
ihren gerade nicht hin weil die
kommunikation immer schon die ist dass
ich den konsens einhole oder zumindest
in einer gelungenen verfügung
da greife ich doch nicht einfach so
platt schick und macht genau das was ich
das letzte mal gemacht habe was
funktioniert hat sondern ich taste mich
da mal vor ich gucke funktioniert das
ich kann es gibt eine kommunikation mit
den augen mit den blicken das muss alles
nicht in form eines juristischen vertrag
seien aber natürlich ist es ein
austausch darüber
die erste reaktion der person die ich
verführen will gibt mir schon ein
anhaltspunkt darüber ob diese person
ansatzweise interessiert an dieser
verfügung sein könnte
wenn wir jetzt so tun als ob die abend
männer die wissen gar nicht mehr was sie
tun sie wisse nicht ob sie verlassen
dürfen also dann tut es mir leid dann
müssen sie vielleicht noch ein bisschen
emotionales wir arbeiten das kann doch
nicht so schwer zu verstehen sein aber
es kann auch nicht so schwer zu
verstehen sein und bei diesem beispiel
nummer zu bleiben wenn eine frau
mitspielt wenn sie erotische fantasien
global teil wenn smsen ausgetauscht
werden wenn man sie endet das
hotelzimmer habe warum jetzt aber wird
sie war halt ein beispiel laut habe es
man rechne in alle möglichen ich wollte
nicht dass gerade man darf man auch
annehmen dass sie sagen auch hier
bewusst wird wie vieh gespielt wird
gerne mal mehr genau das problem besteht
darin dass sie einerseits zu recht sagen
muss wissen wo jetzt die grenze ist und
auf der anderen seite wer solche grenzen
hin kommunikation immer wieder neu
definiert
ja schon aber das problem ist
hoffentlich dahin oder sondern danach
danach dann sagen kann nachdem ich die
grenze nicht so definiert gesehen habe
wie ich es gerne nachmachen eigentlich
dieser ton der anspannung vor wird genau
ich will aber jetzt gerne noch einmal
bei diesen punkt bleiben soll jetzt
dieses eine beispiel so hochgekocht wird
es wird ja oft unterschieden zwischen
individuellen unrecht und so genannten
strukturellen unrecht ein begriff aus
den 70er jahren geprägt von johan
galtung dem friedensforscher der immer
gesagt hat es gibt gewisse unrechts
momente die reproduzieren sich aber um
weil die gesellschaft ebenso gestrickt
ist das gewissen formen des unrechts
bauer und vorschub leistet jetzt könnte
natürlich sagen naja beim itu da ging es
immer irgendwie eben und sexuelle
belästigung und so weiter aber die frage
ist ja auch ist es nicht auch einfach 1
1 auf murren ein aufschrei auch da war
also ein herr stark von frauen die
einfach mal sagen es reicht jetzt
zwitschern die haut primär mal keine
ahnung sexuelle belästigungen aber da
geht es um viel grundlegenderes
eigentlich auch das kommt ja auch vor in
ihrem buch sehr wenn zum beispiel den
gender pay gap also die
lohnungleichheiten ich habe einfach mal
geguckt schilling report 2018
frauenanteilen geschäftsleitungen in der
schweiz sind gegenüber dem vorjahr von 8
prozent auf sieben prozent gesunken
also nichts mit fortschritten sondern
die frauen die haben einfach keinen
platz in der teppichetage na klar aber
noch und er kennt es nicht sein dass
dieses klima auch dazu führt dass die
frau mal auf den tisch hauen also punkt
eins ist tatsächlich und sie haben es ja
schon angesprochen meines erachtens ist
die fokussierung auf den sexuellen
aspekt und auch die tatsache dass dieser
für diese fokussierung so viele mediale
verstärker findet das hat natürlich was
mit aufmerksamkeitsökonomie zu tun ja es
ist einfach wahnsinnig viel sexier und
spannender zu lesen wie frauen davon
junge schöne frauen models davon
berichten wie sie von dem fotografen xy
in irgendeiner form angefasst wurden ja
das liest man natürlich springt auch der
focus ja zeitschriften die jetzt nicht
gerade für ihren feministischen impuls
wahnsinnig berühmt sind also dass das
finde ich ist wirklich der der eine
aspekt dass diese verkürzung auf den
sexuellen aspekt
diese strukturellen elemente gar nicht
einfängt ja die viel massiver sind dann
man kann sagen es gibt natürlich gibt es
sozusagen selbst sich selbst
reproduzieren die seilschaften und und
bestimmte machtgefüge die sehr stabil
sind natürlich kann man das sagen ich
will die männer auch überhaupt nicht
frei sprechen von irgendeiner mitwirkung
unschuld ich glaube nur dass selbst auf
so einer ebene es gut wäre wenn die
frauen auch da sich selber mit
betrachten würden und nicht nur sagen
wenn ihr lasst uns noch nicht rein wenn
die ich gerne aber noch mal sprechen was
würde das heißen
das heißt ganz einfach dass wenn ich
mich zum beispiel in einem ganz
konkreten umfeld um gucke da ist es
durchaus so dass viele frauen es auch
einfach sozusagen das erste kind wird
geboren die frau die bestens ausgebildet
ist ein exzellentes juraexamen hat
verschwindet wie von zauberhand im
privatraum und nicht weil der mann ihr
irgendwie mit der peitsche da steht und
sagt du musst dich jetzt aber ums kind
kümmern sondern weil es auch eine
entscheidung ist und ich glaube dass man
das wirklich klein redet wenn man immer
nur die schuld bei den männern sucht die
uns da irgendwie nicht reinlassen das
stimmt das sind wir wieder bei diesem
bei dieser these dass dieser herr stark
feminismus nennen alles vom staat
erwartet und nichts von den frauen
ich schiebe noch eine kleine frage nach
einfach was mich interessiert ist gerade
das programm der viel kohle raus die
sitzen da in der programmkommission ich
habe einfach kurz durchgezählt das
geschlechterverhältnis 42 zu achten also
schlechter aus 52
könnte man nicht sagen ja sie sind
programmdirektorin sorgen sie doch mal
dafür dass hier mindestens ein drittel
frauen eine stimme kriegen ich habe ja
noch einmal an
heribert frauen müssen wieder reden
können dann würde sich vielleicht etwas
ändern
selbst in der frage der sexuellen macht
verhelfen also den schutz ich persönlich
mir jetzt nicht an weil ich mich
tatsächlich engagiere dass frauen eine
stimme kriegen ja dass das das ist so es
ist aber auch so dass sie merken wenn
sie in diesem ganzen medialen feld und
da sind sie ja auch unterwegs tätig sind
das ist eben oft auch so ist die
erfahrung mache ich zumindest dass man
zum beispiel auch frauen fragte gar
nicht wollen sie sagen mir so ein forum
behagt mir nicht oder mit dem möchte ich
nicht streiten oder so es gibt da eine
sehr große zurückhaltung auch bei frauen
und ich glaube dass diese zurückhaltung
dass das eben auch etwas ist was man das
kann man doch sozusagen selbstreflexiv
betrachten das kann man doch analysieren
woher kommt das eigentlich dass männer
der viel offensiver sind ja klar mache
ich doch kenne ich zwar nicht so gut aus
mache ich trotzdem frauen sind
wahnsinnig gewissenhaft und sein orden
da kenne ich mich jetzt nicht ganz so
gut aus mache ich lieber nicht da sind
auch tun dass jedes thema ist fast so
selten stammtisch sozusagen nicht den
platz sind hier praktisch über fast fast
jedes thema ja aber er kann das auf der
einen seite bestätigen ich veranstalte
auch philosophische tagungen und habe
auch diese erfahrungen gemacht und da
kann man gesondert darüber diskutieren
aber er glaubt dass für das iphone vom
thema art tatsächlich zu tun haben dann
naja sie so schwer man kann nicht immer
alles mit allem verbunden es hängt alles
mit allem zusammen aber wie die erfragt
oder richtig gesagt hat dass er jetzt
wenn wir jetzt ein mieter spricht dort
über sexualität und über gerechtigkeit
und sexuelle gesten und handlungen
das ist nun mal spannender als lohn
verrechnungen und fragen die man
bestimmten konzernen ganz nach oben
kommt wobei schon eines sagen muss ja
und verzeihen sie es mehr was wir hier
für einen zusammenhang mit dieser mit
und abate ist eine absolute luxus
diskussion denn das sind frau und in
hohem maße karriere gemacht haben wie
auch immer das sind frauen die ganz oben
stehen das sind frauen die bei
filmpreisverleihungen
bei großen events ihre stimme erheben
können haben kann jetzt gerade wieder
erlebt das ist jetzt nicht so dass das
tatsächlich die entrechteten sind dies
auch noch gibt auf dieser erde dass er
das hollywood mit also das war ja auch
der vorteil an twitter obwohl sie das so
harsch kritisieren diesen hersteller -
das heißt sie sich ganz viele leute
äußern können
und insofern ich würde ihnen recht geben
dass wir für minister sei auch alle
möglichen anderen themen zu bearbeiten
haben aber ich würde auch sagen dass wir
in gewisser weise die beiden themen
nicht auseinander also ich nehmen dürfen
ich habe jetzt sind wieder mal dieses
großartige buch von beckers soll mit
wanderlust heißt es eine geschichte des
gehens und da gibt es ein kapitel über
die frauen und wo sie noch einmal
nachvollziehen wieso weibliches gehen in
der öffentlichkeit so viel
eingeschränkter ist und also es gibt ja
jetzt noch keine generation von frauen
die nicht irgendwie mit müttern
aufgewachsen sind die ihn gesagt haben
zu gewissen stunden an gewissen orten
lieber nicht allein gehen und also diese
öffentlichkeit als bedrohung dieses ich
gehe nicht frei in die welt hinaus wie
der flaneur wie der naturbursche der war
der romantische dichter in der natur
weil als frau ist man einerseits mit
dieser sittlichen verantwortung behaftet
dass man sozusagen vor sexuellen
übergriffen sich selber schützen muss
und darum sich selber einschränkt und
wenn man nur schon an diesem ganz banale
ein beispiel wie frauen in der
öffentlichkeit sich überhaupt bewegen
und sie geht zieht diese geschichte vom
neunzehnten jahrhundert wo es auch eine
gesetzgebung über prostitution gehabt
die frauen faktisch sehr eingeschränkt
hat weil man jede allein gehende frau
sofort der prostitution verdächtigte bis
ins heute wo es nicht mehr der staat ist
er die weibliches der das weibliche gene
der öffentlichkeit einschränkt aber
diese allgegenwärtige angst vor dem
sexuellen übergriff der nicht immer
passiert aber immer passieren kann und
der sozusagen einer verinnerlichten
zurücknahme im öffentlichen raum führt
und insofern hängt diese saat von von
erfahrung des sexuellen bedroht haid
oder der der sexuell unangenehm mehr
erlebnisse machen können zusammen mit
allem möglichen und auch mit
gehaltsverhandlungen letzten endes also
mit dieser frage wie wir uns wie
selbstständig wie frei und wie
selbstbewusst wenn in der öffentlichkeit
bewegen
gegen diesen schritt weiter und sprechen
jedoch noch einmal jetzt über dieses
thema aus sie schon mehrere male und sie
auf last für aufgebracht haben nämlich
dieses vermischen in diesem herrscht
feminismus also alle die feministischen
bewegung und die eben vor allem in den
sozialen medien fuß gefasst haben die
aufschreie oder eben wie miete und der
vorwurf lautet ja wirklich das eben
dinge vermischt werden also die
strafbare sexuelle handlung jahre
vergewaltigung wird vermischt mit
harmlosen alltags sexismus sandra konrád
eine psychologin die sagt alltag
sexismus ist aber überhaupt nicht
harmlos gibt offensichtlich einen
konsens dass vergewaltigung das ist
wirklich schlimm alles was darunter
stattfindet da sollte frau sich bitte
nicht so anstellen und ich finde als
gesellschaft müssen wir verstehen dass
das zusammenhängt alltag sexismus
sexismus ist der boden auf dem
sexualisierter gewalt gedeiht was denken
sie ist autark sexismus harmlos oder
würden sie bei pflichten der these von
frau conrad
also ich denke ich habe in jungen jahren
hin wir nicht so harmlose sachen erlebt
ist im alter werde ich weniger belästigt
wenn man wirklich in ruhe gelassen
werden will und es gibt keine eu es wird
ein nein wird nicht akzeptiert das finde
ich das ganz ganz schwierig vielleicht
darf ich hier noch nachfragen die ganze
miete debatte was wir jetzt diskutiert
haben fällt ihnen da etwas auf oder
etwas ein muss ich hinten dass ich jetzt
noch völlig verkehrt gelaufen hier am
tisch bei uns ist nichts völlig verkehrt
gelaufen habe ich finde dass die kritik
an miete bewegungen bis hin zu heftiges
leben eines tages wie freiwild
eigentlich musik von klein auf werden
darf ich sie frage nicht erleben auch
wie frei sind
also ich würde nicht sagen freiwild aber
es gibt immer situationen wo ja in denen
man auch nicht weiß wie reagieren als
frau weil wenn ich aufstehe wenn ich was
sagt dann bin ich halt dann die frau die
sich wert das kommt dann auch nicht gut
an manchmal also auch für mich ist es
manchmal echt schwierig die situation so
zu beurteilen wie sie vielleicht zu
beurteilen ist im gesetz
schaftlichen rahmen also es ist durchaus
schwierig ja ich würde gerne von ihnen
wissen wie sehen sie der these von frau
conrad ist back sexismus der boden auf
dem eigentlich die gravierenden formen
von sexismus
ja ich also ich würde überhaupt nicht
sagen dass das harmlos ist oder dass man
das halt ertragen was umso mehr mein
gott stell dich nicht so an
natürlich kann man sich wehren aber man
kann sich eben während der man kann in
der regel einem mann ohne gefahr zu
laufen jetzt vergewaltigt zu werden oder
gewalt zu erfahren in irgendeiner form
sagen ich möchte nicht nein danke oder
ich möchte es vielleicht auch anders ja
vielleicht ist das ja auch der punkt man
möchte nicht dass aber vielleicht jenes
dass das finde ich es eigentlich der
punkt und ich glaube dass tatsächlich
dieser alltags sexismus der existiert
das würde ich auch sagen er hat aber
auch etwas eben mit mangelndem respekt
vor der frau zu tun das ist
kulturhistorisch einfach das ist das
erbe mit dem wir im moment noch zu
kämpfen haben und ich glaube um da
rauszukommen ist es eben wichtig frauen
in die selbstermächtigung zu bringen und
in eine potente position zu bringen und
sie dazu zu bringen die möglichkeiten
die sie faktisch heute in dieser
gesellschaft haben auch zu nutzen ja
weil ich meine dass das finde ich
eigentlich so erschreckend ich hab
manchmal wirklich das gefühl der
feminismus in den 70er 80er jahren der
war so viel weiter der war so viel
offensiver und wir sind dann eigentlich
muss man echt sagen in so einer art
tiefschlaf verfallen dadurch dass der
feminismus sehr stark dominiert wurde
eigentlich von einem feminismus der er
für lesbische und co ihre identitäten
frauen gemacht war das würde ich schon
so sagen also judith butler zum beispiel
ganz wichtige philosophin hat ganz ganz
ganz wichtige dinge hingewiesen hat
gesagt wir dürfen nicht von der frau
sprechen weil dann schreibt man sie auf
ein wesen fest auf ein wesen das
kinderkriegen muss und so weiter das war
ein ganz wichtiger einwand aber ich
glaube das problem war dass dieser
feminismus wirklich die position der
heterosexuellen frau aus dem blick
verloren hat und das finde ich das merkt
man jetzt es gibt diese position
irgendwie nicht mehr und ich habe
manchmal wirklich das gefühl wir wir
schleudern uns jahrzehnte zurück es gibt
ein sehr schönes zitat von simon de buhr
was sie in den 40er jahren schon
geschrieben hat da sagt sie
die zur immanenz verurteilte frau also
die sozusagen
es sitzt in patriarchalen gefängnis die
zieht die männer herab und verstümmelt
verstümmelt sie zerstört sie um
sozusagen ihren frust in irgendeiner
form loszuwerden und um sie um wieder
gleichwertig mit ihm zu sein und ich
habe das waren die 40er jahre und ich
habe das gefühl dass jetzt in der
methode debatte passiert und durch metro
passiert dass es hinab ziehen
das ist eigentlich wieder ganz ähnlich
und wir sind doch einem völlig anderen
punkt gesellschaftlich darf ich einfach
hier noch mal sozusagen der trend
unterscheidung einbringen also mir ist
jetzt noch einmal aufgefallen in dem zu
ehren ihres votums und dem was gerade im
publikum gesagt und sie reden über die
sexuelle begegnung und über wie wir
meistens in privilegierten kontext und
selbst hinterfragen können wir
individuell mit situationen umgehen
ich glaube nicht nur in private gehe ich
glaube und privileg ist aber ich glaube
schon dass man das unterscheiden muss
was ein großer teil von nico war war ja
eben tatsächlich das beschreiben dieser
alltagssituation die freunde becker soll
nicht auch so ein bisschen und das st
konrad auch gesagt hat dass man
permanent in dieser gefahr steht dass
irgend etwas unschönes passiert und egal
welchen grades also das was mit freiwild
gesagt wurde und ich glaube dieses das
müssen wir schon verknüpfen natürlich
mit der frage wie wir uns sexuell
begegnen weil es zusammenhängt der ddr
der mangelnde respekt vor frauen in
unserer kulturgeschichte der hängt
natürlich auch mit einem verständnis von
sexualität zusammen aber ich würde es
trotzdem irgendwie unterscheiden wollen
und das ist auch glaube ich dass was
mich am meisten befremdet sozusagen an
ihrem ansatz weil ich eigentlich
natürlich alles dass wir potentere
frauen brauchen und ein das aktivitäts
passives system schema durchbrechen
müssen dass da gehe ich alles mit ich
finde bloß nur den anlass das anhand
dieser sexuellen übergriffen und
missbrauchsfällen zu diskutieren
irgendwie falsch also das hat wiederum
margaret ist da kommst doch eigentlich
ganz gut gesagt das ist wie wenn man
sich über vergiftetes essen er beklagt
und und dann sagt als jemand aber warum
genießen sie nicht auch gutes es aber
das hat auch schon den punkt das meist
vergiftete essen in dem fall nicht so
klar unterscheiden kann ja aber ist
schon wieder einander zusammen einfach
glaube trotzdem dass man es immer wieder
unterscheiden muss
wir können diese größere debatte über
sexualität führen und ich finde wir
müssen die führen in dem sinne finde ich
das wertvoll aber ich für
es tatsächlich diese polemische
abgrenzung von dem was wirklich wichtig
auf den tisch bringt nämlich dieser
dieser respekt mandl der eine faktische
freiheitseinschränkung von frauen
bedeutet die das ist ein thema was damit
zusammenhängt und was wir ansprechen
müssen
vielleicht sollte man nur mal so
nebenbei und den ein kleiner fußnote
sagen dass es natürlich auch das
verhältnis in der anderen art und weise
gibt es gibt auch sozusagen verkehrs
formen und formen von belästigung wo der
mann sich eingeschränkte fühlen kann
mag sein dass das natürlich nicht
dominant ist aber dass diese erfahrung
gibt es auch und das zweite ist ins
spiel gehen
natürlich gibt es auch stark erinnern
nein und es gibt auch massive weibliche
psychische gewalt also wenn ich mich
jetzt ist es übrigens interessanter
punkt wenn man sich jetzt wo manchmal so
klein familien an guckt so in meiner
generation da ist es nämlich oft so dass
der mann eher so eine wahnsinnig
lächerliche randfigur ist die eigentlich
quasi keine rolle mehr spielt also der
kern ist eigentlich kind und mutter und
der mann der kreis irgendwie so neben
planet irgendwie um dieses zentrum man
hat wirklich das gefühl der wird auch
also wirklich systematisch klein
gehalten ja also das beobachte ich in
meinem umfeld immer wieder
das heißt also da einfach nur zu sagen
es gibt diese männliche gewalt die frau
wird also so einfach ist die tatsächlich
leben und würde das wirklich fußnote
also ich möchte es nicht ins zentrum
rücken krankheiten stimmt natürlich ja
es gibt es in form von alltags sexismus
es gibt diese vorstellung ist das gefühl
ständig ausgesetzt zu sein oder wird rot
zu sein es gibt diese zone wo man sich
allein nicht mehr hin traut es gibt auch
schon einen modernen städten was man
allein nicht mehr getraut übrigens und
natürlich fragt man sich dann also wir
gesellschaft organisiert sein muss und
wie die begegnung zwischen den
geschlechtern organisiert sein muss
damit diese gefühle zumindest minimiert
werden ganz wenn man sie nie weg kriegen
weil es immer asymmetrische beziehungen
zwischen menschen geben wird und ich
glaube erotik es früher schon ein
bisschen angedeutet worden
erotik ist prinzipiell ambivalentes
verhältnis erotik ist prinzipiell zwei
deutsche also alle versuche erotische
beziehungen auf eindeutigkeiten
festzuschreiben töten die erotik das
daran lässt sich nichts ändern man keine
dafür sein dass man das tötet ja aber
besonders auch laut und deutlich sagen
ist das eine das ich haben wir
vielleicht eine gedanken und das zweite
ist weil gesagt wurde und völlig zu
recht gesagt wurde wir zuschauen wenn
wir diese sagen jetzt mal sexuell
erotische kommunikation intern
organisieren immer ein gefühl dafür
entwickeln was in bestimmten situationen
möglich ist und was nicht möglich ist
ich sehe so seien zwei tendenz in
unserer gesellschaft das eine ist das
hat uns gestern schweden vorgeführt
verrechtlichen verrechtlichen
verrechtlichen das heißt so wenig als
möglich wirklich der entscheidung des
einzelnen überlassen sondern so viel als
möglich tatsächlich rechtlich
vorschreiben einklagbar machen bis hin
eben zu punktuellen verträgen über die
eine oder andere erotische begegnung man
kann darüber philosophisch sehr
geteilter meinung sein und auch sehr
interessant darüber diskutieren ich
hatte das im grunde nur für exzessive
ausdehnung des kantischen ansatzes dass
sexualität weil sie ihm als sexualität
dann an dann immer zum objekt machen
muss es geht nicht an dass im akt der
sexualität ist da anders für mich
lustobjekt auswärtig er ist kein subjekt
und das hat er kann schon gesagt muss
jede frau von sexualität vertraglich
geregelt sein
denn nur da im vertrag wäre die würde
des einzelnen noch gesichert der sich
notwendigerweise zum objekt machen muss
bekannt war jetzt nicht sehr erotisch
also sozusagen spritzig sste hat auch
gute gründe sich auf habe verträge
persönlich erst gar nicht eingelassen
wird schon gewusst und warum das heißt
also wir haben die chance auf der einen
seite die möglichkeit der total
verrechtlichung das ist das eine und das
andere ist wir können wie in vielen
bereichen unsere hoffnung einfachen
technik setzen
ich halte das was wir hier debattieren
zum teil für eine antiquierte debatte
junge menschen die ihre dates über ein
digitales datingportal organisieren sind
versorgungsfragen mehr oder weniger
gefeiert
denn wer sich auf kinder verabredet weiß
genau warum auf diesem portal ist warum
der antrag auf dem portal ist und was
man zu erwarten hat wenn man sich dann
gemanagt haben sich
da muss ich heute nicht vorstellen was
ihm hier unter sexueller belästigung wir
aus nach zeigers mehr ausmacht
nachhelfen nachschauen wahrscheinlich
und ich körper kommt ich glaube
tatsächlich dass der körperkontakt
kinder auch noch passieren muss und dann
wird es wiederum schwierig ich finde das
jetzt müssen wir viele dass sie diese ja
konsens dem guten alten etwas
vertrockneten erkannt und so schieben wo
man sich ja ungern
das ist vollständiger sexuelle kanzlerin
so seien outen möchte aber ich glaube
tatsächlich dass der gegensatz der immer
wieder aufgebaut wird der all diesen
fragen darf man noch lernen und so
weiter zu grunde liegt nämlich dass eben
verführung versus konsens dass der ein
falscher gegensatz ist wenn man sich die
sexualität geschichte also ich ganz grob
kategorisiert gibt es meiner meinung
nach ungefähr 33 motiv von sexualität
die wir kennen das eine ist sexualität
als machtausübung also vergewaltigung
decree als im krieg oder so weiter oder
literatur senior der herr der sozusagen
die die verfügung sexuelle verfügungs
gemacht macht hat wollen wir alles nicht
das ist kein modell das andere und das
ist das weitaus dominante modell im
abendland ist sexualität als
dienstleistung als dienst- und pflicht
der eheliche sexualverkehr ist ja
geregelt dass es nicht immer so dass nur
die frauen sozusagen sechs dem man
schuldet umgekehrt wird das auch immer
wieder betont das kann zu
stresssituationen auf beiden seiten
führen die eheleute sind zu sexuellen
sie einander zu sexuellen
dienstverpflichtet auch ein schönes
antwort nicht wahr und das dritte modell
und damit experimentieren wir wirklich
erst seit wahnsinnig kurzem weil die die
großen diskussionen die über
vergewaltigung in der ehe abliefen die
hatten genau damit zu tun dass wir auf
dieser stelle standen zwischen eheliche
pflicht sexualität und sexualität als
konsensmodell des sexualität soll nur
genau dann passieren wenn zwei leute
darauf lust haben und das auch wollen
und jetzt können wir den willen
problematisieren wir können den los
problematisieren weiß keiner genau was
er will aber es gibt kommunikation und
wir reden drüber und sei es mit den
augen und bevor ich in diese brustwarze
greife gucke ich ob er das mag weil mein
letzter liebhaber mochte es aber der mag
es vielleicht nicht und das dass es
existiert als konsens es ist nicht der
ehemann der müde abends haben sagt in
allen schwarzen in der kasse
nein ich die nein aber die erotik
braucht die überschaubar ist es
langweilig wenn man wenn man sozusagen
zuerst diesen raum wurde im gleichen
fehler machen muss man ein bisschen
drastisch
also ehrlich gesagt eine guter sex ist
selten dem ersten mal gefallen man muss
sich nach rantasten bis man so ungefähr
weiß was funktioniert und bekommt die
kasse darüber dass was ja was ja hier
diskutiert wird ist ja wirklich die
frage inwiefern kann man genau diese
problematik und die ganze tiefe
ambivalenz der sexualität die sie jetzt
wer glaube ich auch deutlich machen ja
durch einen redebeitrag inwiefern kann
man darf quasi delegieren ans recht und
und sagen das recht muss jetzt im grunde
das für einheit für für eindeutigkeit
sorgen und das recht muss jetzt im
grunde genommen den sex regeln dass das
und da gibt's erstmal ganz pragmatische
probleme nämlich wie will man beweisen
dass in einer situation in der keine
gewalt
das hat es auch bei den immer einen
nachweis es gibt ja es gibt ja jetzt
erste zahlen sozusagen also die die
anzeigen gehen
rasant in die höhe seitdem ist doch du
dir sprechen sie soll deutschland von
der verschärfung des strafrechts in
deutschland keine debatte die in der
schweiz in dieser art und weise führen
die frage ist aber inwiefern kann man es
an das recht delegieren das ist also ich
halte das für quatsch zu sagen man
delegiert ist das recht spiegelt den
stand des der gesellt des
gesellschaftlichen konsenses jetzt haben
wir uns als gesellschaft aber jeden dass
wir nicht mehr sex als dienstleistung im
ehelichen nur ehrlichen
selbstverständlich soll konsensual sein
und dann muss das recht das spiel das
heißt aber der wille der erkennbar aber
wenn es relevant und nicht die tatsache
ob sich der andere schreiend und um
gewalttätig gewährt hat aber das aber
das problem dass es rechts wäre wenn das
so wäre dann würde das recht im bereich
des sexuellen und der sexuellen
begegnungen zurückgehen denn menschen
können etwas nur frei aushandeln wenn
sie nicht rechtlich eingeschränkt aber
das ist das mehr als drei aushandeln
sollen und ich auch in seiner einführung
der vergewaltigung kreiert umstritten
war
jedes mal wenn man versucht das
sexualstrafrecht an die jetzt geänderten
gesellschaftlichen konsens verhältnisse
anzupassen
gibt es ein riesiger aufschrei wir
machen diejenigen anklagen
wir machen im schnitt weil ich doch noch
einlösen möchte wenigstens noch kurz auf
diese auf diesen vorwurf zurück zu
kommen des moralischen pranger war
darüber haben wir nämlich jetzt noch
überhaupt nicht gesprochen
und lassen sie uns das noch mal machen
leider kevin spacey zum beispiel ist
eine rolle los in house of cards oder
die ausstellung von chuck close in
washington die wurde abgesagt wegen me
to vorwürfen
was ist denn die alternative also wenn
ich noch einmal die mary bord nehmen
möchte die sagt natürlich naja aber wenn
wir so was die mieten nicht haben wollen
dann sagen wir doch auch so was wie
frauen haltet den mund nach einer der
herren aber sorgen gibt noch einen
dritten weg aber man kann doch nicht
aufgrund von verdächtigungen ausstellung
absagen bilder entfernen weil sie
irgendwie vielleicht sexuell an ruhig
ich wunder mich ja das gustav coupe
jules rimet überhaupt noch hängt also
jemand das ist doch das problem also man
kann doch nicht aufgrund von
verdächtigungen existenzen zerstören
dass das ist einfach das finde ich
wirklich bin ladens einer die frauen die
twittern oder wer wir genau wo würden
sie denn den vorwurf vororten wer macht
was falsch ist und wir waren jetzt den
vorwurf seinen frauen verorten sondern
bei einer gesellschaftlichen und einer
medialen umgebung die das aufgreift und
genau diesen druck erzeugt dass man
heute wirklich aufgrund von
verdächtigungen
gerade in österreich ganz prominent
peter pilz und politiker der gerade
nachdem er einen wahlsieg errungen hatte
erinnerte verdächtigung ausgesetzt war
sein mandat nicht antreten konnte
zurücktreten musste als vorsitzender
seiner soeben neu gegründeten partei
jetzt zwei drei monate später stellt
sich heraus alle vorwürfe laufen ins
leere
die staatsanwaltschaft legt das zurück
aber seine karriere ist ruiniert
das heißt also die art und weise wie wir
mit diesen mitteln umgehen zeigt unter
anderem unter anderem auch noch eines
das wir mittlerweile vollkommen
verlottert das verhältnis zu dem haben
was wir früher mal rechtsstaat genannt
haben nämlich das so zu sagen bevor ein
beweis überhaupt geführt worden ist ja
bevor nicht
sozusagen gerichtlicher entscheide
getroffen worden sind hat immer geheißen
im zweifel für den angeklagten heute
heißt das du bist angeklagt ist schuldig
egal was hinterher herauskommen und
sozusagen jetzt die methode watte
verlässt und prinzipiell zu einem
phänomen sozial am leben wir der klare
jemand nahm er ist schuldig weil er
angeklagt weil ist aber dann kann man
das was sozusagen 200 jahre arbeit am
rechtsstaat waren können wir dann
begraben
heute noch vielleicht noch zwei noch
zwei sachen sagen interessant ich habe
freunde in wdr in deutschland erwähnt wo
es jetzt diesen fall gab wo eben der der
mann freigestellt wurde es gab jetzt
eine weitere anklage es wurde noch
jemand angeklagt von frauen
und da haben sich jetzt aber andere
frauen vor diesem mann gestellt und habe
gesagt das geht nicht dieser der hat
nichts gemacht ja also also das heißt es
gibt mittlerweile auch unter den frauen
durchaus auch da eine große skepsis wie
weit das eigentlich gehen kann weil es
kann ja wirklich nicht sein dass jetzt
irgendwie in einem öffentlichen
öffentlich rechtlichen sender
reihenweise kollegen frei geschmack muss
aber auch sagen ganz viele frauen werden
auch so schnecke gemacht zb in
kommentarspalten da ist es ja wiederum
so dass die meisten gemeinden kommentare
sich gegen frauen richten also wir
wollen jetzt auch nicht so tun als
würden nur männer messe als zur schnecke
gemacht ist teile das geht nicht darum
zur schnecke machen es geht nicht darum
mögliche ziele raues klima einen
sozialen medien
auch das könnte man mal debattieren was
hier sozusagen auch für verlust von
kommt von sensibler und intellektueller
kommunikationsfähigkeit zu beobachten
ist es geht also nicht darum dass man
hier sozusagen wird da nicht nicht
feinen klinge arbeitet in kommentaren in
postings in sozialen medien sei es geht
darum dass das ja sagen rechtliche
konsequenzen hat das menschen entlassen
deren mandat nicht antreten
wir freuen auf all die ihren
ausstellungen geschlossen werden et
cetera ist ja ganz was anderes als nur
ungestört kommentare abzug also ich
würde ja in vielen sehr pessimistisch
ich teile nicht vollständig irgendwas
muss über die verortung des
rechtsstaates ich stelle auch fest und
zwar weit über das was im engeren sinne
untermiete im allgemein gefasst wird
weiter eine tendenz dass man
heutzutage relativ schnell und
hysterisch reagiert auf sensible
anschuldigungen aller arten und deshalb
wirklich nicht nur mit sexismus zu
bringen oder in sechs von haus zu haus
am fast eben meist geht es um eine art
vorauseilendem gehorsam man kann sie
hier sagen hier wird
hier wird oft so ein bisschen das kind
mit dem bade ausgeschüttet es wird ein
bisschen vorschnell gehandelt
andererseits muss man sagen man könnte
auch kultur optimistisch sagen also es
wird so auf die anständigkeit gesetze
der immer schön wenn jemand nicht in
seinem amt verbleibt bis er wirklich
rechtlich daraus geklagt wird sondern
sagt okay ich nehme die verantwortung
ich gehe es sind ja auch schöne
politiker tugend indem wir ihn früher zu
schätzen wusste also es gibt doch jedem
fall eine gefahr dass diese dieser
kultur kampf in dem wir uns befehl
dieser grabenkampf zwischen sozusagen
konservativen stänkern in der rechten
ecke und linke münsterischen so seine
empörung auf der anderen seite dass man
sich da irgendwie so ein bisschen zu
sehr aufgebauscht
das ist alles geschenkt deshalb dieses
entwicklung der methode batterie sind am
ende unserer diskussion mittendrin ich
glaube wir könnten locker eine stunde
weiter diskutieren leider haben wir die
zeit nicht habe ich danke ganz ganz
herzlich für diese engagierte diskussion
vielen vielen dank
gerne gespielt
ja und auch ihnen zu hause danke ich
ganz herzlich für ihr interesse
nächste woche ist schon sehr weiß dass
einer der berühmtesten im moment
lebenden philosophen weltweit er ist 85
jahre alt und sagt mit dem tod da
sollten wir nicht zu früh uns in
akzeptanz üben sondern einfach mal sagen
es kommt noch sehr viel
hier kommt jetzt nicht mehr sehr viel da
stand ist ist leider zu ende aber ich
möchte doch noch einen hinweis machen
wir zeigen nämlich aus aktuellem anlass
jetzt gleich ein porträt über den
verstorbenen schriftsteller philip roth
das sollten sie sich auf keinen fall
entgehen lassen
ich wünsche ihnen eine gute woche
herzlichen dank fürs interesse wieder
sehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]